check it out it's so beautiful
that's why you were being so suspicious
[Music]
hi i'm ashley my name's jesse i have two
kids i have a 15 year old and a
seven-year-old and buzzfeed
is giving me a hundred dollars to make
my daughter's dream costume hey annie
if you could have any costume what would
it be
the haunted mansion ghost this is an
extra special costume
because we got to go to disney world in
january right before
the pandemic happened and the kids were
pulled out of school we've always loved
the haunted mansion and when we first
moved into our house the one thing that
sealed the deal
was the wallpaper when you first walk in
my daughter demanded that we frame it
because she loved it so much and it
turns out it was almost identical to
the haunted mansion wallpaper today
we're doing the costume for my
seven-year-old daughter
emma her dream costume is actually
selena which is the 90s to hano music
artist
she is someone that has become so
revered in the last 10 years
this year marks the 25th anniversary of
her passing
my daughter's dream costume is an icon
[Music]
okay so the kids are outside so i have a
few seconds to
show you my inspiration for this dress
this is my favorite halloween barbie
so hopefully i can recreate that dress
this purple took me a really long time
to find keeping this a secret is going
to be
a huge challenge i just have to tell her
that i'm making a barney costume or
something
i don't know anything that's purple so
now i'm trying to match her
up with fabric i was very happy with how
closely all these colors match
the dress so there are a few things that
are going to get in the way of this
challenge
there are no patterns for this costume
and i'm just doing it with my hands so i
haven't made something like this
in a really long time but now that i am
sitting here doing it
everything that was impossible before
is suddenly coming back to me like that
celine dion song
it's all coming back
oh my god i actually don't know how to
sew that well i'm really bad
i do not sew i actually don't know how
to put this
on so my best friend and roommate is
gonna help me
oh that's bad i'm going to tell my
daughter that i am making her a vest
and i'm going to take construction paper
and hold it up to her
and trace around it okay
so put your arms out
just making it best the fact that we're
in quarantine so keeping it a secret is
kind of the
whole point of this so we're doing
homeschool this year so it has been
really impossible for me to find time
when no one is climbing on me so
i have to be extra sneaky what are you
doing
i'm making my costume oh have you ever
started a project
and you're like oh that'll take like
three hours and then you look at all of
your stuff
and you start thinking about it even for
a second and you're like oh no no no no
no that's about that's like three months
of work
it's not even straight yeah it's like
definitely not even
i wonder if glue guns are frowned upon
on
project runway i feel like tim gunn
would be really disappointed
[Music]
here i am with a dress i am about to go
show it to annie
i'm nervous but excited yay
[Music]
hey annie can i show you something
do you know what this is it's one
amazing dress
yeah that's why you were being so
suspicious
and three check it out
it's so beautiful it's a selena costume
even the thing yeah do you want to try
it on
yeah i am so excited to see you wear
this
do you think it'll fit um
do you love it can you spin around
can you dance like selena
annie you look
amazing do you like it yes wow
[Music]
you seriously love it yes you definitely
look like selena
only probably i'm a kid that's
amazing do you feel spooky
[Music]
[Music]
hey what
[Music]
you